freunde herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video und dies irgend einem video
wir machen heute die wahrscheinlich
einfachste pasta der welt auf zwei
zubereitungsart zum einen die klassische
schwerer begriff die amateur art und
weise wie wahrscheinlich jeder von euch
schon mal nachts um zwei bedrohungen
gemacht hat als er nach hause gekommen
ist doch im detail ist das zumindest
legen das ist ein brand ist und dann
einmal die profiversion und zwar von
aglio e olio der name mario heißt
knoblauch olio heißt dementsprechend
relativ simpel das rezept ist
selbsterklärend hier sind unsere zutaten
das haben beide gerichte gemeinwohl
insel petersilie jetzt kommen wir zur
amateur variante die haben klassische
spaghetti wir haben chiliflocken wir
haben knoblauch und drüben haben wir
besondere spaghetti was sie besonders
macht erzähle ich euch noch frischen
knoblauch und frischen ich bin gespannt
wie groß der unterschied zwischen den
beiden zubereitungsarten wirklich sein
wird weil ich persönlich würde sage ich
schon was erwartet einen welthit
unterschied dass in diesen kleinen
spielfeld auf dem wir zu einer bewegung
bin sehr gespannt wir beginnen mit der
amateur version wir seit unserer
nudelwasser und einfacher könnte ein
rezept nicht sein dass ich glaube das
ist so great khali all das sind alles
sachen so da ist der name das rezept
aber glaubt man vielleicht hier
schnappen uns als erstes mal unseren
knoblauch so wie man ihn in jedem
supermarkt bekommt alle euro darf man
oder sollte man auf jeden fall nicht am
knoblauch sparen auch bei amateuren wir
den kleinen trick machen wie so ein
bisschen an zu knacken ende abschneidet
dann ist sich das ganze schon doppelt
geschnitten die fahne habe ich jetzt
auch schon mal angemacht und ich gebe
ordentlich hören ich glaube das ist in
beiden rezepten der absolute
grundvoraussetzung weil das halt einfach
unsere null los ist und direkt ihre
unserer öl heiß wird gebe ich schon mal
ein paar von unserem chip trocken sein
ich sage ehrlich wie auch sonst wird's
in amateurvideos
glaube auch hier ist die amateur version
einfach geil das ist nichts wofür sich
hin und niemand schämen muss zwar geht
die oso zu machen weil es einfach kosten
übels geil ist wer die nudeln kochen und
unser öl geschmack annimmt kann ich euch
sagen von dem ich das rezept habe wenn
ich dich gleich befolgen werde und zwar
von alex tew rennsteig ein absoluter
kochen nerd wir sind ständig auch schon
länger verfolgen die gabmann amateur
oder profi version kochen ist es glaube
ich relativ rat sondern dass man die
basics kann und versteht ich kann man
auch an mir arbeiten und ich werde es
auch mit skoda nicht alexis mantrailer
auch einen eigenen kurs mit fünf
episoden wurde die grundlagen auf den
weg zum chef kommt entleert aber eins
sei gesagt er ist noch viel viel mehr
und zwar ist geht ja eine online
community mit mehr als 13 millionen
mitglieder sollen die möglichkeit haben
von den besten der besten zu lernen neue
fähigkeiten zu erlangt einfach indem das
geht besser zu werden du kannst von
boden willst mit jedem endgerät ob
laptop tablet auf wie auch immer seine
kurse buchen und anschauen und wenn du
etwas sehr gut bist kannst auch du deine
skills mit anderen ausgehen verteilen es
geht ja funktioniert über ein abo modell
das heißt ihr könnt einmalig bezahlen
und müssen nicht jeden kurs dann noch
mal eins und mit auch diese haben weil
sie können euch ausprobieren und nach
und nach neue inspirationen gibt es
beispielsweise eine spezielle fähigkeit
die du lernen möchtest dann ist der
perfekte ort um damit anzufangen ob du
food fotografie freiberuflichkeit
irgendwas weiskircher kannst du von
einer internationalen community lernen
das gute ist alles verfügt über deutsche
untertitel und jede woche jeden monat
erscheint neue premium kurse so juden
sind fertig die schiffe die ab1000 von
häufig können kostenlose pro monat über
meinen link in dem stadion haben deshalb
schaut vorbei danke ans geschäft weiter
mit aioli entspanne knoblauch und chili
eine schöne portion und so müssen wir
das ganze jetzt einmal schön durch wir
sehen diesen typischen fettfilm der sich
hier auf die nudeln gelebt hat ist
riecht köstlich der knoblauch ist das
ist auch bei der amateur war natürlich
wichtig nicht geträumt also noch so dass
er nicht bitter wird wer das noch nicht
gegessen denkt vielleicht bewusst die
soße schwarzer pfeffer wir machen uns
einen teller und wir nehmen und passt
dann lassen natürlich nichts im handel
zurück was ist denn jetzt kommt auch
noch und ob zum schluss da nehmen wir
das ganze noch mit der kleinen
geschnittene petersilie
lasst euch sagen es sieht auch nicht
verkehrt auch eine amateur version also
durch ich weiß ja nicht was zugleich
macht er sehr gespannt ich habe extra
das video nicht geschaut um auch so ein
bisschen überrascht zu werden höchstens
feiern und ich glaube es könnte sein
dass wir nie wieder diese rolle war also
probieren wir das ganze ist duftet
wirklich die petersilie sich total
frisch die haben aber auch eine
knoblauch note offensichtlich sind auch
drei ganze 10 bringt chilis sind
eingewoben in die pasta gerade wenn man
ordentlich hunger hat wie ich gerade bin
ich mir sicher schmeckt das auch
wirklich christlich
schöne schärfe aber ja knoblauch note
und chili note gemeinsam das sind
einfach schon legendär man vermisst auch
hier um ehrlich zu sein keine lust habe
ich das gefühl jetzt einfach trotzdem so
üblich ist dass gründer wie geschmiert
im wahrsten sinne des wortes das öl hat
auch eine schöne rote farbe angenommen
zweifelsohne eine sehr leckere pasta
aber ich freue mich wirklich jetzt die
version von alex auszuprobieren und es
wird deutsch richtigen kommen wir jetzt
zur profiversion ich muss sagen es hat
sich einiges hier im setting verändert
was vielleicht auf den ersten blick
nicht auch selbst zum einen habe ich die
fahne gewechselt das wird später
relevant aber beim einkaufen das ist
hier nicht teuer versus billig der waren
ein bisschen teurer der einkauf aber
sind kleine aber keine unterschiede die
passt ich gekauft habe und die erste
eigenheit ist dass diese pasta mit
bronze ausgeformt wurde also aus der
nudelmaschine kam die nicht aus einem
keramik aufsatz was normal ist bei
normaler fast sondern aus einem bronze
aufsatz und das macht einen kleinen aber
feinen unterschied wenn man die beiden
nudeln unterscheidet fällt sofort auch
dies ein bisschen heller wird eine raue
oberfläche und diese klassische
telegraph verwendet haben ist flach
durch die ausformung mit bronze wird ein
höherer druck nötig weshalb die
oberfläche griff wird dass die passt
dann es abbildet und gleichzeitig wird
mehr stärke abgeben also ist hat einige
vorteile die einzige nachteil ist dass
die hier ein bisschen teurer ist bei der
herstellung ein bisschen aufwendiger wir
nehmen auch nicht irgendeine menge passt
da genau nach 60 grad jetzt genau 160
grad misst dann kriegst du einen kurs
kurz für mich auch wenn man es in der
hand hält merkt man das ist einfach ein
anderer schnack das ist einfach eine
andere nudel diese ganzen vorbereitung
die ich da mache nennt man mühsam platz
in der französischen küche das heißt
bereitet alles vor dass ich gleich beim
kochen nicht in stress verfallen weil
ich da noch schneiden wir nehmen unsere
petersilie und zupfen hier perfekt die
blätter ab so dass nur die stiele zurück
bleiben dann sieht das ganze so aus die
schmeißen wir auf jeden fall nicht weg
kommen jetzt unserer chili auch hier
greifen wir auf frische chili zurück
dadurch dass ich sage dass ich wie komme
ich dass ich ein profi bin weil ich mein
sowie schneider habe ich den skater kurs
auf ihr verbringt nötig wir schaffen uns
jetzt knoblauch hier habe ich frischen
knoblauch geholt haben hat eben gesehen
wenn ich nur noch dinge für die amateur
variante verwendet haben waren in der
mitte schon so keine drin die euch
einfach dringend kann man auch aber hier
das problem auch gehen kann ich nehm 210
oder hort und eine mit einer in der
schale des menschen wir einmal unseren
anderen knoblauch schneiden die feine
würfelchen dass er quasi eine soße über
den fall
die merck schon bei der pro variante
legt ihr einfach insgesamt mehr wert auf
präzision der teufel steckt im detail
erinnern so schön so wir machen unsere
beiden herde an und der erste
unterschied ja direkt auffällt ist zwar
der gleiche topf aber ein drittel vom
wasser banks wir verwenden wie gesagt
die nudeln geben mehr stärke ab wir
werden das nudelwasser nämlich gleich
verwenden um unsere soße die bisher
keine war wirklich zu einer zu machen zu
decken zu innovieren es wird ganz ganz
wichtig für uns mit weniger wasser hat
man eine höhere konzentration von stärke
der einzige schritt denn gleich drei und
geben ordentlich olivenöl hinein und
können dann direkt unsere ganze
knoblauchzehe und unsere petersilien
schnell hinein nehmen unsere chili
können wir ebenfalls schon dazu geben
und so aromatisieren jetzt das will auch
hier setzen wir das wasser wieder gut
wir müssen nur aufpassen miteinander ist
model wasser später darüber geben
wirklich nur stärkt darüber kommen
sondern auch salz deshalb vorsichtig mit
dem satz bekommen
jetzt gehen wir unseren nudeln hinein
wir haben eine angegebene kochzeit von
neuen linken wie kommen sie erst mal für
sex wollen sie nämlich nicht ganz
durchdacht aber man sieht schon direkt
die trübt das wasser geworden ist
schnappen uns jetzt die ganze
knoblauchzehe und die mittlerweile
frittierten stängel und gehe mit der
hitze ein wenig hoch wir nehmen uns ein
wenig von unseren müll wasser geben dass
hier zu
reduzieren alles was wir da drin haben
bei feuchtigkeit verdammt bleibt mehr
geschmack wind und wir kriegen eine
dickere soße alles richtig mache haben
wir eine soße am ende man muss einfach
viel mehr bei der sache sein als bei der
amateur kaster immer wieder gucken noch
ein bisschen wasser was braucht meine so
nutzen versprechen jetzt sollten unsere
nudeln soweit sein und wir geben sie
einfach so wie sie sind mit dem rudel
wasserratten anhaftet in unsere große
hinein so haben wir jetzt unsere
situation jetzt muss aber meine küche
riskiert muss auf jeden fall mehr für
diese passte arbeit muss 100 prozent
mehr arbeiten jetzt gehen wir mit
unseren geschnittenen knoblauch und ein
bisschen frischer schnee die noch mal
ran womöglich allein anguckt was jetzt
schon an nudelwasser hier drüben in die
falle gegangen aber guck mal bitte hier
wir sehen hier an den nudeln anhaften
unsere sorte die perfekte textur für
unsere soße wenn das der fall ist geben
wir unsere petersilie dazu aber matti
sieren sie auch noch mal in der pfanne
hörst du das siehst du darfst hier ist
unsere soße
nahen und hast du eigentlich gleich
zitat mal andere passt
ein wenig stolz auf der verkäufer und
natürlich so eine italienische piazza
darf man sich mit löffel ist es war geht
die radiologie noch nie gegessen haben
es ist wirklich ein anderes gericht ruft
jemand immer hier so ganz nah dran so
siehst du das ja man hat schon bei man
also beim machen hat man schon gesehen
dass das eine ganz andere pasta sein
wird auch ist es einfach verrückt wie
viel die richtige technik ausmachen kann
wie unterscheiden sich die beiden hast
dass diese hier bist viel edler so man
hat gefühlt verschiedene schärfen nun
mann hatten viel rundere vier runden
geschmack und man hat vor allem das
gefühl man würde was leichtes essen soll
diese cremige soße die wir wirklich
gemacht haben ich sage ich mit dieser
pasta hier kannst du blockt herzen
erobern das ist nur die machart
unterschiedlich man würde für diese
passe so instant fünf euro mehr bezahlen
also mindestens deswegen ist alleine
weil ich diese person von keinem
restaurant gegessen habe keinen respekt
an die amateure version aber gehe ist in
stufe ich sage euch so viel es dauert
nicht nicht mal bedeutend länger macht
diese passte einfach vertraut und dann
kam alex da dieses rezept hier gezeigt
hat sein videos auch verlinkt und danke
fürs zuschauen dabei wird nicht nur drei
zu verstehen
davon könnte zu 500 essen